ความสำเร็จของ VQE algorithm ของเราขึ้นอยู่กับ
state และ circuit
ที่เราเลือกเริ่มต้นอย่างมาก
ฉันชื่อ Victoria Lipinska และในวิดีโอนี้
เราจะสำรวจตัวเลือก
ที่เรามีในการออกแบบพวกมัน
มาดูให้ละเอียดขึ้น
ที่ element ทั้งหมด
ที่เรามีในทุกการรัน quantum
part ของ VQE
เราเริ่มด้วย reference state
ที่บางครั้งเรียกว่า initial state
เราเรียก reference state
ผ่าน parameterized circuit ที่เรียกว่า
variational form
ด้วยการเลือก parameter เริ่มต้น
และเราวัด state
ใน basis ของ Hamiltonian
หลังจากเรียกมันผ่าน circuit
เพื่อให้ได้ expectation value ตอนนี้
เราจะผ่าน element แต่ละอย่างเหล่านี้
เริ่มด้วย reference state
ทางเลือกทั่วไปสำหรับ reference
state คือ zero state
นั่นคือ state ที่ quantum
computer ถูก initialize ไว้แล้ว
สำหรับปัญหา quantum chemistry
คุณยังสามารถใช้ที่เรียกว่า
Hartree-Fock State ด้วย
ซึ่งเป็นผลลัพธ์ของ
Hartree-Fock method
พูดง่ายๆ Hartree-Fock
theory ให้วิธีง่ายๆ ในการสร้าง
reference state โดยการประมาณ
ground state ของ quantum system
มันหาการหมุนภายใน
space ของ state
ที่ minimize ground state energy
สุดท้าย reference state
ยังสามารถเฉพาะเจาะจงกับปัญหามากได้
และคุณอาจต้องการเลือก
custom state
ในกรณีที่คุณรู้ว่าระบบของคุณมีคุณสมบัติอะไร เช่น symmetry
หรือจำนวน electron ที่ระบุ
ใน state คุณสามารถใช้สิ่งนั้น
เพื่อให้ได้การ converge ของ VQE
algorithm ที่ดีขึ้น
การเลือก reference state ที่ดี
มีความสำคัญต่อการ converge
reference state ที่ใกล้เคียงกับ
ground state
สามารถทำให้ปัญหา converge
ได้ง่ายและเร็วขึ้นมาก
สำคัญพอๆ กันคือ
การเลือก initial parameter value
ที่เราป้อนเข้า variational form
ดังนั้น ขึ้นอยู่กับ reference
state และ initial parameter
เราอาจ converge ได้เร็ว ช้า
หรือไม่ converge เลย
มาดู plot นี้
และเพื่อการ visualize
ให้จินตนาการว่า space ของ parameter
ของเรามีแค่ parameter เดียว
reference state ที่ดีมาก
ทำให้คุณเริ่มต้นได้ใกล้มาก
กับ final ground state
แล้วการ converge จะเร็ว
ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าคุณเริ่มต้นห่างมาก
จาก ground state ตรงนี้
reference state
a จะต้องข้ามกำแพงพลังงานสูง
ทำให้ converge ช้ามาก
หรือไม่ converge เลย
เราจะพูดถึงสิ่งนี้ให้ลึกขึ้น
ใน classical optimization module
ในคอร์สนี้
มาดู parameter circuit
ที่กระทำบน reference state หรือที่รู้จักกันว่า
variational form กัน
เมื่อ circuit นี้ U ของ theta กระทำบน reference
state
มันสร้างสิ่งที่เราเรียกว่า trial state
psi ของ theta หรือบางครั้งเรียกว่า ansatz
ansatz state นี้แหละที่ถูก
วัดใน basis ที่เหมาะสม
เพื่อให้ได้ expectation
value ของ energy
variational form
ที่เราพูดถึงที่นี่
ได้แรงบันดาลใจมาจาก chemistry
แต่จำไว้ว่า
มียังมีอีกที่ได้รับแรงบันดาลใจ
จาก quantum machine learning
และ near-term อื่นๆ
algorithm อย่างเช่น quantum
approximate optimization algorithm
มาพูดถึงทางเลือกทั่วไปบางอย่าง
สำหรับ chemistry ansatz
Unitary coupled cluster หรือ UCC
เป็นวิธีที่เสนอในตอนแรก
ใน VQE publication แรก
และมักใช้กันใน quantum
chemistry problem
โดยปกติ
เมื่อเรา parameterize quantum state
เราทำงานกับ parameter จำนวน
มากแบบ exponential
แต่เพื่อให้ preparation
circuit มีประสิทธิภาพ
เราต้องการจำนวน operation
แบบ polynomial
และจึงต้องการจำนวน parameter
แบบ polynomial ด้วย
UCC เป็นตัวอย่างของวิธีการเตรียม
trial state ด้วย circuit แบบนั้น
และมัน derive มาจาก coupled cluster
method
ซึ่งเป็น golden standard
ใน quantum chemistry
ทางเลือกที่พบมากที่สุดคือ unitary
coupled cluster
singles and doubles
ansatz หรือ UCCSD ย่อๆ
เพราะ UCCSD ได้แรงบันดาลใจจาก
electronic configuration เฉพาะของปัญหา
เราต้องมั่นใจว่าเรามี reference
state ที่สะท้อนระบบอย่างถูกต้อง
นี่คือ Hartree-Fock state
UCCSD ansatz มักให้
การประมาณ ground state ที่ดี
เพราะมันครอบคลุม single และ double
electron excitation ใน molecule ที่กำหนด
จำนวน parameter ใน UCCSD scale
แบบ quadratic กับจำนวน
spin orbital
UCCSD สามารถ tailor
ให้เข้ากับปัญหาได้ดีมาก
แต่น่าเสียดาย quadratic scaling
ยังทำให้ circuit ลึกมาก
ซึ่งยากสำหรับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ในปัจจุบัน
นี่คือเหตุที่นักวิจัยของ IBM เสนอ
แนวทาง heuristic มากขึ้น
ที่สามารถ tailor variational form
ให้เข้ากับ hardware พื้นฐาน
ซึ่งทำให้ได้ circuit ที่
execute ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
นั่นคือ trial state ถูก parameterize
โดย quantum gate
และถูก adapt
ให้เข้ากับ physical device ที่มีอยู่
นี่เป็นแนวทาง heuristic มาก
ที่เป็นมิตรกับ hardware
จากตัวอย่างเหล่านี้ มาดู
spectrum ของความเป็นไปได้
ที่เรามีในการแสดง
variational form ของเรา
หลายอย่างเหล่านี้
ถูก implement ใน Qiskit แล้ว
ดังนั้นฉันแนะนำให้คุณลองด้วยตัวเอง
ว่าอันไหนเหมาะสมที่สุด
สำหรับปัญหาที่คุณพยายามแก้
ถ้าเราดู graph ในด้านหนึ่ง
เรามี heuristic มาก
variational form
เมื่อ problem specificity ต่ำ แต่
พวกมันถูกออกแบบให้ implement
บน real hardware ได้
พวกมันยัง expressive สูงด้วย
ในแง่
ที่สามารถแสดง
quantum state ได้หลากหลายด้วยพวกมัน
แต่ปัญหาที่อาจเกิดขึ้นในช่วง
ของ classical optimization
คือการพบกับ
สิ่งที่เรียกว่า barren plateau
ซึ่งเราจะพูดถึงใน module ถัดไป
ในอีกด้านหนึ่ง
เรามี unitary coupled cluster ที่เฉพาะเจาะจงกับปัญหาสูง
ซึ่งทำงานได้ยอดเยี่ยมใน classical chemistry แต่
ยาก implement บน quantum
hardware เนื่องจาก circuit depth ใหญ่
โดยทั่วไป การคำนวณ
จะสำเร็จได้มากกว่าถ้าคุณสามารถ
ก่อนอื่น เลือก reference state
และ initial set ของ parameter
ที่สร้าง ansatz state
ใกล้กับ ground state
และประการที่สอง หลีกเลี่ยง parameter ที่ไม่จำเป็น
parameter เหล่านี้อาจทำให้
circuit depth ใหญ่ขึ้นโดยไม่ได้ผลตอบแทน
หรือสร้าง parameter space ที่ใหญ่ขึ้น
เพื่อ search ทำให้เกิด plateau
ใน classical optimization
parameter ไหนที่จำเป็นเป็นปัญหา
เฉพาะที่ต้องการ
การคิดอย่างรอบคอบ
มาพูดถึงว่า guest of honor ของเรา
Hamiltonian ซ่อนอยู่ที่ไหนในทั้งหมดนี้
อย่างที่เราเรียนรู้ในส่วนก่อนหน้า
Hamiltonian หลังจาก qubit
mapping ถูกแสดงเป็นผลรวมของ
Pauli operator string ที่มีน้ำหนัก
ในที่สุด อย่างไรก็ตาม
เราต้องการ evaluate expectation
value ของ Hamiltonian ของเรา
บน ansatz state ที่สร้างโดย variational form
โชคดีที่ quantum
mechanics เป็น linear ที่ดี
และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราจะใช้
เพื่อให้ได้ expectation value
มันทำงานแบบนี้
เรารู้ว่า Hamiltonian เป็น weighted
sum ของ Pauli
เนื่องจาก linearity
expectation value ของผลรวม
เท่ากับผลรวมของ expectation
value ของ Pauli string แต่ละตัว
ดีมาก เพราะอย่างที่คุณรู้อยู่แล้ว การวัดใน Pauli basis
ง่ายพอๆ กับการหมุน
ของ standard measurement basis
แทนที่จะวัด expectation value
บน Hamiltonian ใหญ่ๆ ที่ถูกแสดง
เป็นผลรวมนี้ เราก่อน evaluate expectation
value ของ term แต่ละตัว
แล้วรวมตอนท้าย
ด้วย weight ที่สอดคล้องกัน
นี่คือเหตุที่ใน resource จำนวนมาก
คุณจะเห็นแค่ single qubit rotation
หลังจาก ansatz
นี่คือสิ่งที่ implement Hamiltonian
ในทุกการ execute ของ circuit
ในวิดีโอถัดไป
เราจะสำรวจว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
ระหว่างขั้นตอน classical optimization
แล้วเจอกันที่นั่น